18:39 and some chap has just ordered the
destruction of some opium lin seshu was
the name of this man a Chinese official
who'd confiscated the opium from a man
called Charles Eliot the British had
been making a lot of money selling it to
the Chinese because opium is incredibly
addictive the Chinese government had
banned its import and sale because it
was ruining the country but that didn't
stop the British because money
seshu had hoped that this open display
of defiance would deter the British from
continuing to sell opium to China he was
wrong as a result Eliot who oversaw all
British trade with China ordered the
withdrawal of all British men and ships
from Canton and out of the country
the British were furious that the
Chinese thought that they were allowed
to tell them what to do in China and so
they mobilized the Royal Navy for war
seshu wasn't concerned about war since
he felt that the British would only win
at sea but on land the Chinese were safe
the British fleet arrived at the island
of Joe shown here in 1814 demanded that
it surrender the inhabitants said no and
dug in for a long siege on July the 5th
of 2:30 the Royal Navy began its
bombardment by 239 the bombardment was
over and the islands defenses were
completely destroyed the British then
took the island with no further
resistance the First Opium War had begun
in earnest
the Chinese led by the daoguang emperor
of the Ching dynasty didn't take the war
the British very seriously at first a
part of this came from the entrenched
Chinese belief that all foreigners were
barbarians who were destined to live
under the rule of the Emperor this is
demonstrated by the fact that during the
war they referred to the British not as
foreigners but as rebels the British
under the leadership of Foreign
Secretary Lord Palmerston expected the
war to be a difficult one it was about
two things the first was obviously the
right to continue selling opium to the
Chinese the second was to end the idea
of Chinese superiority and to be seen by
the imperial court as equals in all
things anywho while sailing up the
Chinese coast the Royal Navy had
attempted to deliver a letter of their
peace terms to the Emperor the Emperor
largely ignored these demands and
instead decided that Britain would be
happy if Flynn seshu was removed he had
him replaced with the man called ki Shan
who met Elliott in late 1840 to discuss
terms
hisham promised that a peaceful solution
could be found and told the Brits to
simply wait until the Emperor date to
reply to them months passed and the
British were unhappy to wait anymore
so in early 1841 back to fighting the
British were victorious at the Battle of
Chimpy in ki Shannon Eliot meant to
discuss terms in late January Eliot
demanded Hong Kong the reopening of the
opium trading can't on a bunch of cash
and for the British to be recognised as
equals the Emperor said no and hurty
sham arrested and
placed him with two men the emperor's
cousin yi Shan and the general could
yank Fang the task was simple crushed
the British entirely the intensity of
fighting picked up soon after this and
by March the British were sitting
outside of Canton yank Fang agreed to
allow the British to trade their again
in return for the soldiers leaving which
they did the Emperor was furious and
removed yang Fang and demanded that ye
shall now destroyed the British because
that's how that worked
Canton was reinforced while the British
took defensive positions around the city
he shall attacked the British on the
21st of May he was repelled and about a
week later the city was captured by the
British and looted during this battle
the Qing forces outnumbered the British
about fifty thousand to six thousand so
why did the British win the two main
reasons were technology and training
whilst China had been the birthplace of
gunpowder most Qing soldiers were
equipped with Spears or bows and those
that had guns had old matchlock muskets
whereas the British had much newer
weaponry and their soldiers were also
very well trained and were often
veterans of other conflicts unlike the
Ching who were mostly peasant conscripts
who sometimes fought bandits
this discrepancy was much larger at sea
where British warships were of much
better quality than the Chinese ships
could junks that they faced the British
had also brought with them a brand new
warship the HMS nemesis which was an
iron hold steam-powered warship which
outlast anything the Ching could throw
at them the pattern of a much larger
Qing force being defeated by a small yet
technologically superior British force
continued throughout the rest of the war
over the next year the British captured
many coastal cities and forts amid 1842
the British captured cinque yang which
meant that they could blockade the
Yangtze River in China's Grand Canal
which meant the food couldn't be shipped
across the Empire the Emperor thus
decided to sue for peace with Britain
and they both signed the Treaty of
Nanking the terms were that trade would
now go through these cities as well as
Canton and that this trade would include
opium that China would pay Britain what
is technically known as a boatload of
money and that Hongkong would be ceded
to Britain as well in return the Chinese
got sweet nothing in this treatise
referred to as the first unequal treaty
for China the Treaty of Nanking marks
the beginning of a period known as the
century of humiliation in which China
would suffer internal rebellions in
degrading foreign interventions one of
which was the Second Opium War but
that's for another video I hope you
enjoyed this episode and thank you for
watching and a special thanks to Winston
Kay with James Bissonnette ozark a flash
Henry Robin Adam Harvey and Skye
Chappell
if you'd like to learn more about the
First Opium War then there are some book
recommendations in the description below